[Music]
well thank you everyone for coming
appreciate you coming out and joining
this session I am Kyle's story I'm a
computer vision engineer at Descartes
labs and today I want to tell you about
how computers see earth machine learning
approach to understanding satellite
imagery at scale and so there's a few
things that I'm hoping depending where
you're coming to this talk from that you
might take away first I'll I'm hoping
that everybody will understand how we've
been able to build a platform within the
Google cloud how that's allowed us to
provide an efficient development
environment for building machine
learning models and then scale those
models across large data sets to be able
to understand the entire globe
second I'm hoping that you will take
away the types of problems that we've
found compelling and that we've been
able to address using satellite imagery
and machine learning techniques and then
third hopefully gets you thinking about
the types of problems that you might be
able to address with these data with
this type of infrastructure and how you
might be able to address some of your
business problems whether that's you
know interest monitoring infrastructure
supply chains agriculture even
understanding the natural ecosystem so
the world is teeming with activity
whether that's man-made infrastructure
like here in the zoom-in sports stadium
inside of a city or that's agriculture
shown here with crop circles in south
america or the natural ecosystem there
are things happening all over the entire
globe all the time and satellite imagery
is a particularly effective way of being
able to zoom in and understand what is
going on all across the globe so it's a
there's a big dynamic range and what we
want to be able to understand we want to
zoom all the way in to the human scale
of a few meters or a meter or less and
then we simultaneously want to be able
to extend these analyses across
countries and continents so it presents
a big challenge within satellite imagery
we are at the beginning
what we think is of as a regime change
in just in simply just the data set so
previously satellites were big and
expensive you know costing of order a
hundred million dollars weighing a ton
companies and governments could only
send up a few of these at a time
and so while these satellites provide
excellent and incredible information you
can't monitor the entire globe with any
sort of regular cadence with the advent
of cube SATs and smaller satellites
that's really changing so now companies
are able to build satellites for 60 70
thousand dollars a piece these small
things and then they can launch entire
fleets up into the sky to be able to
effectively monitor the entire globe
almost in real time and so what we're
looking at for the near future is where
as the data that underlies Google Earth
takes approximately two years to
complete a new picture of the entire
world we expect that within around five
years private satellites will be able to
cover the entire globe every 20 minutes
so this is a completely different class
of the types of problems that you can
address and then also a completely
different regime for the big data that
you need to deal with in order to make
sense of all of these these information
so Descartes in order to make sense of
these data we're building a living
digital atlas of the globe and so during
this talk I want to tell you a bit about
that and then how we're using machine
learning to understand the value and the
information in these pictures so we can
think about this as a classic Big Data
challenge with the three V's volume
variety and velocity and so in this
context volume is what it usually means
the massive amount of data that we need
to be able to pull in and work with
variety in this case means the different
types of data that we want to synthesize
into analyses and I'll talk about all of
these in more detail and velocity here I
really mean two things
I mean first being able to access all of
that data efficiently but then also
being able to analyze and scale your
analysis across the globe rather than
having someone look at individual
pictures so to kind of work through
those in with some numbers in a bit of
detail
global goal satellite data sets are very
big this composite that we made is
comprised of three point one trillion
pixels per band and the Landsat
satellite that took this has collected
over seven seventy trillion pixels
between 2013 and 2017
so that's comprises three hundred 20
terabytes on disk and that's just one
saddle mele among many so we have we've
processed around 10 to 12 terabytes of
data sorry petabytes of data on to our
platform at this point and this is just
going to expand exponentially but just
to give you you know a bit of an image
in your head of what that looks like
let's take one satellite the Sentinel
satellite and take all of the picture
that it's taken and print each
individual band out on a one millimeter
thick sheet of paper stack that up and
that would form a column that's 410
kilometers tall so from the surface of
the earth up into the thermosphere so
it's just it's a lot of data the data
variety that we're working with comes
from different types of sensors that we
want to be able to work with and
synthesize together so here on the left
there are passive sensors like normal
pictures that you would take on in the
middle there are active sensors which
actually send down rate radiation or
radar and then receive the signal and
interfere it to get 3d information about
the surface of the earth that's called
synthetic aperture radar and then
there's near-infrared data that actually
measures the thermal emission from
sources on the ground and then there's
all kinds of other geo relevant data
like whether cellphones derived products
dry mass customer data so we want to be
able to put all this into the cloud in a
way that customers can access in an
efficient way
to be able to build these types of
analysis algorithms and then velocity so
thinking about the how long it takes to
to work with these types of data let's
consider again the sentinel satellite so
if we take one year of data seminal
satellite covers the entire earth
approximately once every five days let's
now chop up the entire earth into 512 by
512
tiles at 10 meter resolution and then
give a human analyst 10 seconds to look
at each picture that would take them a
hundred and 30 years to go through one
year of satellite data for one satellite
so obviously that's silly we're not
going to do that but that kind of
illustrates the problem of the the old
way of thinking about satellite imagery
analysis and why we need new approaches
and then also the four-velocity thinking
about the computation that's required to
handle these types of data so again
coming back to this composite that we
created this was made from processing
over a petabyte of NASA imagery and we
did all this processing within the cloud
using preemptable VMs and by spinning up
30,000 cores we're able to process and
create this image in under 16 hours and
this also Dementieva sets but it
demonstrates the capability that google
cloud will be able to scale as the data
that I'm talking about continues to grow
in the way that we expect so to handle
all of these data as I mentioned at the
beginning we're building a data refinery
or a platform to better understand our
planet and so what we want to provide is
ready access to petabytes of geospatial
data and then scalable compute to back
that up and be able to create automated
and scalable analyses these are just a
few of the satellite sources that we
have on platform right now and this is
going to just continue to grow so I've
talked a lot about all these you know
all this raw data but what's really
important is that the value lies in the
information in those pictures and the
decisions that you can make from that
information not in the raw pixels so
it's important for us to be able to sift
through all of that data and arrive at
decision points all right you know being
able to monitor something in supply
chain or make a decision about whether
we're gonna go here go there so being
able to pull together all different
types of data so here is SAR over Tokyo
what you see the ships coming into port
being able to understand the changes
over time this middle
image are segmented crop fields in
Nebraska that were created by looking at
detecting edges and images and then
looking at which edges persist over time
to be able to tell what fields or what
and then using machine learning which
I'll spend the second half of my talk
talking about to be able to analyze all
these data at scale and then what this
gives you is really a geospatial
refinery for business intelligence so
again taking all this data processing it
and then turning into value and
decisions that you can use so what the
platform actually looks like then is
effectively a Python API for Earth
that's what we like to call it so let's
say for example you want to take we want
to gather Sentinel imagery over talus in
northern New Mexico if you were to start
from scratch trying to go directly to
the satellite source this would be quite
challenging but for us it only takes
three four lines here importing the
package specifying the location doing a
search over all of that giant catalog of
metadata to find the Sentinel imagery
over this place in 2017 between March
12th and March 20th and then taking all
of those numbers and burning them into
an image or a picture that you can
actually see and work with so under the
hood what we've provided is fast access
to over a petabyte of data on this on
the platform the search function for
searching through the metadata is done
with elastic search and it provides
millisecond response times over all of
those data and then an automatic tiling
system so you don't have to worry about
pulling together different images and
making sure you register them correctly
all this if you want more detail about
the underlying platform you can go back
and watch tim's talk from yesterday
io 2 6 3 so the second half of the talk
I want to talk about the machine
learning approach that we've taken to
trying to understand these data and
derive value from it so I think another
important change that at least the
geospatial data community is going
through right now is where as
previously images were thought of as
something that a human analyst could
pull up on their screen and then look
through and study and annotate with with
this massive amount of data as I
mentioned that's no longer sufficient
and so we should start thinking of these
images and all of these data as input to
computers input to algorithms what
computers are seeing out of this rather
than what humans are seeing out of this
and it really changes how you think
about the type of analysis and the type
of questions you can answer and so
that's what's going to be required to
automate data analysis that can you can
scale across the globe and then this
also encourages us to simply think
differently about the types of questions
that one can answer so hopefully I can
get you all thinking through this talk
so a little bit about what the input
data looks like from so now me as a
computer vision engineer I come in and I
say how am I going to create a new
useful tool so let's start with the
input data as I mentioned previously
there are several different types of
images the most common are passive
sensors where the Sun is the light
source shines reflects off the surface
of the earth and you take a picture of
that reflected light so that's like
normal CCD cameras then there are active
sensors which are their own light source
so like for example synthetic aperture
radar which sends a radar signal down
reflects it off the surface of the earth
and then receives that full wave front
which it can measure and interfere and
then use that to reconstruct 3d models
of the ground so we collect these data
and what many of the algorithms that I'm
be working with are supervised training
supervisor algorithms and so often times
it'll look like image target pairs so
here for example on the Left I have a
picture of a city of high-resolution
satellite imagery and then on the right
I have a labeled image for where all the
buildings are and so this is the type of
input data that would go into training
and algorithm these data are because the
cloud the platform is in Google Cloud
it's trivial to be able to process all
of these data and create these pairs
directly in the cloud and then save them
to cloud storage
and then be able to access them
seamlessly without having to use any any
local resources for those of you who
think about analyzing imagery I just
wanted to highlight a few of the
similarities and differences between
processing normal imagery so many things
are similar but there are some key
conceptual differences so in particular
satellite imagery usually has an own
size and scale with units pixels usually
correspond to a specific size on the
ground in terms of data augmentation
these images are left right and
rotationally invariant so you can flip
them around to augment your datasets
easily one of the key differences is
that often times were interested in
finding things right at the limit of the
resolution of the imagery so small
objects within images whereas in normal
imagery whether it's the cheese example
that we saw from Otto and Mill that
piece of cheese takes up almost the
entire image here we're looking for you
know you saw the buildings we're looking
for those little specks so the scale in
terms of a transfer thinking about
transfer learning the scales can be
different there are almost always
confuse errs in the data like clouds
haze and shadows so that requires a lot
of pre-processing and I'll show a little
bit later dealing with that and then in
normal imagery there's usually three
bands whereas in satellite imagery we
can have an arbitrary number of bands
for example the Sentinel satellite from
Europe that I've referenced a few times
has 12 bands from the visible all the
way up into thermal bands and then a you
know similarity that works well with
being working within the cloud is that
these problems are generally
embarrassingly parallel you can take the
full stack of images and normal image
processing or you can tile up the earth
into a stack of images and then send
them off to an arbitrary number of
processors to be able to run that run
those jobs in parallel okay so now we've
thought a little bit about the input
data how do we want to analyze these
data well there's three sort of
dimensions that I like to think about
when thinking about saddle
spatial spectral and temporal so spatial
is just where you are on the ground
so the 2d context of where you are on
the earth or within an image spectral
are the different wavelengths of light
that we record when we take imagery in
different bands and then temporal is for
a given location obviously as you take
pictures over time you can see what
changes and so by combining these these
different aspects in different ways we
can access different types of problems
so you know for example computer vision
will usually be combining spatial and
spectral information where you're trying
to understand the spatial context within
an image and then look for spectral
signatures of different types of objects
or land-cover that you want to be able
to find and map and spectral and
temporal can often be used to look for
and monitor change so for example
looking at crop fields over a growing
season you can see how the how the
plants are growing and changing over
time and then obviously many of the
final solutions will be hybrid
approaches that will combine everything
and I'll talk about one of those at the
end so because we have chosen to work
within Google Cloud building these mo
models has is a really efficient process
so we work with in virtual machines on
Google cloud platform that allows us to
easily scale the resources that we need
to process images train algorithms as
needed and then we're able to maintain
environmental consistency from that
development and training process all the
way through to deployment by using
docker and kubernetes because our data
live in Google Cloud it provides a super
fast access to that giant body of data
and then for training we can download
smaller sets to the m's or work with it
directly from the cloud and then we can
deploy at scale so as I mentioned most
of these are embarrassed at the
deployment stage most of these models
are in an embarrassingly parallel
problem and so we can simply spawn up an
arbitrary number of processors if I want
to run a model over you know the world
or over the United States I can just
spawn up that number of processors and
get the results that much faster and
then results are saved directly to the
cloud
so it makes it from it from your
research to building models to deploying
those models working within the cloud
provides us an incredibly efficient
environment for doing this work okay so
now I would like to tell you about three
different more specific machine learning
approaches that we've taken and the
types of problems that we've been able
to access with those so I'll dig in a
little bit deeper into the the machine
learning side of the models for building
so first its object detection and for
those of you who are not computer vision
engineers the basic idea of object
detection is exactly what those words
sound like you want to find objects and
so for example here we're looking for
electric substations so you want to find
that object draw a box around it and say
there it is the particular
implementation that we've been working
with so far is called a single shot
multi box detector SSD single shot
because it takes a single forward pass
through the architecture multi box
because it uses a set of predefined
boxes rather than dynamically finding
those boxes and then detector because it
no detects things how it works in one
slide is the this algorithm as I said
predefined a set of boxes and then for
each of those boxes it uses a
convolutional neural net to generate a
set of features and then finally predict
the confidence of whether or not that
box contains the object of interest so
basically it boils this search problem
down into a classification problem so
here this is from the paper that defined
this architecture you know the blue box
has the highest probability of finding
of being a cat and the red box has the
highest probability of being a dog so
we've taken that and modified it to work
with satellite imagery and here's an
example of the results of that process
so using Open Street Map for the known
locations of electric substations we've
been able to train this using NAIP
imagery so that's the national
agriculture imagery program that covers
the United States this particular data
set has imagery at 60 centimeters per
pixel and for bands and we've trained
this algorithm to
be able to find all the rest of the
substations in the United States and
obvious so that was one example and once
we have this set up with all the imagery
easily accessible and the modeling
framework in place it's easy to train a
wide variety of models across the
industrial supply chain to be able to
find these objects so here are just two
examples of being able to find storage
tanks be able to find boats but you can
just let your imagination run wild for
what you would be able to do with this
the second class of models that we
worked with a lot is called semantic
segmentation the so the basic idea with
this as opposed to bit as opposed to
object detection where you're trying to
find objects here you're trying to say
for every pixel in an image is that
pixel part of a class or not so in the
example on the left hand side is the
high-resolution imagery again from nape
and the right hand side is the
probability of whether or not each pixel
is inside a building so similarly how it
works here we define a deep
convolutional neural net and
convolutional neural nets are a
particularly effective architecture for
these types of analysis because they
take into account the two-dimensional
context of an image so they so when
you're if you're if you've ever zoomed
in on Google Maps and then zoom the way
out and to try when once you zoom all
the way into pixel scales it can be
really hard to tell what you're looking
at and you actually need to zoom out and
be able to see that spatial context
that's kind of conceptually what
convolutional neural nets are able to
capture so we define a deep neural net
architecture in this case a unit and
then these create a bunch of these image
target pairs that I mentioned at the
beginning so in this case about 10 to
20,000 of these and then train the model
within the within the cloud platform and
this is what the output looks like so
these are detection from my model over
LA County so you can see the
high-resolution imagery on the far right
hand side this is the raw probability
map output and then in the middle this
these have now been segmented into
individual buildings and so what's
especially powerful here
is once we have this model as I
mentioned earlier being able to run this
over large areas so I was able to map
all the buildings in California bite
hitting run going home sleep and then by
the time I got back in the morning we
had a map of all the buildings in
California and in principle we can do
this over the entire world
another type of siming segmentation that
we've been able to have success with is
using neural nets to mask out clouds as
you remember at the beginning I
mentioned this is one of the pernicious
problems with satellite imagery as
clouds exist I watched two hour bane
bane of our existence I would say rather
and so by training a neural net to find
clouds and cloud shadows we can now
automatically mask out these out of
images and then be able to remove those
parts from the analysis and this is you
know this can always get better this
will be an ongoing challenge but this
has been a particularly successful
approach for being able to deal with
these types of non ideologies in the
data another approach is what I've
called here course segmentation so this
is actually basically the transfer
learning approach where we start from a
ResNet 50 a pre trained algorithm and
then we tap into one of the lower
resolution feature layers and then
simply add a final classification step
to say whether or not each each of those
coarser pixels is the type of thing in
this case windmills that we're looking
for and so we've taken advantage of the
fact that residents been able to train
on many many many many images and then
with a relatively small number of
examples I think of order a thousand a
few hundred to a thousand examples here
we've been able to train an algorithm
that can find and map windmills so this
has been done across the United States
and across India and then finally it's
still semantic segmentation but a bit of
a simpler model is simply pixel
classification so taking that remember I
mentioned the spectral information
within each pixel what what you see in
different bands and then feeding that
into a random forest classifier and
just training it with a bunch of data to
say whether or not each pixel is land or
water so this is in the Mekong Delta and
you can see it clearly gets the oceans
and the rivers and then there are a lot
of rice paddies in these areas so that's
kind of what the speckling pattern that
you see throughout the Mekong Delta is
here a third type and this is fairly
different is what we've called visual
search so I'll demo this in just a
second but the idea is that this is a
website that you can go to you can click
anywhere either in the United States or
on the earth and it will simply find
other places that are visually similar
so let me go into a little bit of detail
and what's going on under the hood and
then we can play around with this a
little bit so what's going on is that
we've taken the entire datasets the
entire globe we've chopped it up into
lots of little pieces and then we feed
each of those pieces through a
convolutional neural net to produce a
set of features and then we simply
search for nearest neighbors of features
so in you know even more detail than
that we started from a customized ResNet
50 so started from ResNet 50 using all
of that the training that had gone into
producing that model and then remember I
mentioned that often times you're
looking for small things and images that
are different from normal image
processing so we fine-tuned trained that
with the OpenStreetMap data set and then
also some unsupervised autocoding Auto
encoding to be able to produce a useful
set of features we then encourage those
features to either be 0 or 1 so
binarized that set of features and the
result of that process is that for each
tile we get 512 binarized their bits
near 0 1 then we can simply search for
they search for which sets of features
are close to each other and using a
Hamming distance in so we defined that
distance using a Hamming distance and
then we search for it using an
approximate hash based nearest neighbor
search and so the result if I can switch
over to the other laptop oh yeah
okay so this is now the website running
live and so on any of you can go to this
at searched at Descartes Labs calm
so first let's play around with the
United States so this is this national
agriculture imagery program data set
that I've mentioned a few times and so
highlighted a few popular searches but
let's click on wind turbines so what
what this has done is I've grabbed this
tile and then like I said it is
we've already indexed the entire United
States into these 512 bit long feature
vectors and it simply searches for other
ones that are similar so it's pulled up
a whole suite of different wind turbines
all over the country so you know some
here in the Midwest some in the
Northeast and this is not you know this
is not a specifically trained model I
didn't have two input and I didn't have
to know anything about wind turbines to
be able to create this this is just
simply searching for visual similarity
another one that I thought was kind of
neat was the solar farms so let's looks
like this is a solar farm maybe in
Arizona or New Mexico and so yeah so it
click on that and solar farms look very
similar so this does quite well yeah at
picking up solar farm installations so
let's then also look at the entire Earth
so we've done this with the Landsat data
set as well and so you know same idea
being able to index the entire globe
so pivot irrigation are a very unique
signature so I can click on that and all
of a sudden I can see pivot irrigation
in Australia all over Africa you know
the sub-saharan in the United States
down in South America all right so it's
a it's a it's a very powerful tool to be
able to effectively search the entire
globe for things so you can go to this
today and say huh I want to you know I
want to look for railway stations that
look similar to the one near my house
let's click on that and see see where
else they are around the world and so
this is this incredibly fast search and
so you can you can see how how quickly
we're able to Zoomer
this is all enabled by having the
platform built within the cloud so if I
can go back to my talk slides perfect so
with the with those two approaches we
there we basically have a two-stage
approach to performing searches when
when we say we want to try to find some
type of thing because we have because of
the capabilities of the geo visual
search we can do a low capacity a quick
search for things like like the wind
turbines just click on that or build out
a small model and say you know let's
just try to find roughly where some wood
turbines are and differentiate them from
corn fields or forests or whatever and
then if if that's enough for your
particular solution super cheap super
fast and easy you're done no work then
obviously many solutions will require
much higher precision like mapping out
buildings for example wouldn't work with
that and so then we can develop a higher
capacity model that takes you know more
time and effort and so that you know
that's what the examples I showed with
buildings or wind turbines or power
substations and then of course the last
type of models I want to talk a little
bit about our hybrid models in an
example of something we've done that
sort of pulls all these pieces together
and so what this is is one of the
original models that Descartes labs
produced which is the corn forecasting
model so the goal is to be able to
forecast corn production for the United
States so first as I mentioned earlier
using the temporal information we can
segment out which where different fields
are and what those field types are so
how this actually works underneath is
because we have time series imagery over
the United States we can just use normal
image processing to find the edges
there's an edge detection within those
images and then we can look at which
edges persist over time and use that as
a way to segment out field boundaries
then once we have those feelin down ders
it becomes a classification problem so
taking into account the the spectral and
the spatial context information we can
classify those fields here these are
either corn or soy corn yellow and soy
and green and what you're actually
seeing here is the fields like field
classification released by the US
Department of Agriculture with a lot of
measurements on the ground and what you
see here is what Descartes released six
months ahead of time so the well you
should say is hey look those look pretty
much the same and they should because
the US Department very culture accuracy
is quite good the key is that we are
able to do this in effectively real time
rather than having to wait six months
and then the final step of that model is
a regression problem so saying we have
historical data we know how much
production corn production corn was
produced in previous years so let's run
this model and fit to a model to predict
how much corn can be produced and so you
pull all those pieces together and what
the graph on the right is showing is the
y-axis is the uncertainty on how well
you have predicted corn so small
uncertainty is good so down is good you
can see and then as a function of time
and so you can see on as you go to the
far edge of the graph and so you extend
a time they they approach the same
accuracy but the blue decart labs points
got there way earlier and so this gives
this gives businesses and customers a
real actionable insight that that they
can turn into into real value and money
so that's wrapping that up if you any of
you are interested in building models or
have this brings up ideas feel free to
come up and talk to me there's
information on our website and then you
can email either of these email
addresses and I'd love to talk to you
more about what types of problems you
might be able to approach with these
types of data or more questions about
how we've been able to build out all
this infrastructure and our platform
using Google
so with that thank you all for coming
you